things we just saw a man with his hand
pressed up against the window of a coach
he was saying goodbye to his family he's
from luhansk he fled to kharkiv he said
goodbye to them they're going away and
he's going back to join the ukrainian
army and you hear stories like that
again and again these people are in a
queue for a bus we've talked a lot about
trains the bus is actually carrying a
lot of people
out of uh leve it's almost all as you'll
see sort of women and children and and
some foreign
students but you do hear a lot of tales
um let's see if we can grab
a word with julia who who's here we we
introduced ourselves to her a little
earlier julie i know he puts protava
between
kiev and kharkiv and sumi telling me
why are you here
because
[Music]
my baltava city near whiskey and sumai
and kharkiv and it's dangerous very
dangerous and i
come to live and then maybe washaba
poland
how did it's a very very difficult
decision isn't it for you
but we must do to do something i don't
know we must do this
yes my family stay in baltimore
i
come to this place i don't know what
then
you want me to help you move forward in
the queue i don't want you i don't want
you to leave your place in this one
julie um and and tell me how are you
feeling about how what's your emotions
about what is happening in ukraine
i want to come back really i think maybe
russia
stop
this
blood and putin stop because it's idiot
idiot president of russian federation
and i think i come back to my home
really to my relatives i hope
i hope
you you're being very strong and i see
this so many ukrainian people are are
resilient and strong i mean the love for
the country is very clear
yes i think we are
we are strong people
and i think we must
to
[Music]
we
we must to
[Music]
whatever you can yeah
i think putting stuff and we come back
home really that's your dream
it's it's my dream and i think it will
be yes
julia thank you very much henry we wish
you thank you maybe maybe it's not good
but your english is excellent thank you
it's a lot better than my ukrainian
julian thank you very much
indeed and i do think that that sense of
resilience i've heard from so many
people around here look this is a this
is a grim and miserable situation for
people who take pride in their country
and we're on the the eastern extreme of
of europe here this is a country wants
to join
the european union it when it left the
soviet union it its aspiration
was for normality now it finds itself
caught in this this horrendous and
uncertain war and you have this
incredible blend in places like this of
of pride and strength and resilience
all the while in a cocktail with with
fear and anxiety
and nervousness and that sense of of
dislocation
and that is the challenge that ukraine
is facing on a physical emotional level
as well of course of the the horrendous
scenes we're seeing
a few hundred miles away